but uh you went on your RV trip I did
yes four days yeah four days 12 hours of
live streaming a day God damn yeah yeah
long time but I think it went really
well let me see what your hour is in
yeah right yeah you get my get the old
hours and yeah you know how it is uh
yeah it was really fun uh very stressful
very very stressful very tiring of
course of course you wake up one hour of
prep and then go live and then one hour
of prep and then sleep rinse and repeat
Jesus and sleeping in an RV is
that sucks oh that's a pretty big RV
though right like yeah you got the best
bet as well though I had the best badge
but it still sucks so what the [__] are
you complaining about you got the double
bed yeah I know it's over really a
double bed it's not a queen listen it's
like it's a cushion cushion okay and the
and so I rented like so when I uh rented
this RV you could you could take a bunch
of things you wanted to rent with it and
I rented like the sleeping bags and the
pillows yeah and I I mean you know I'm
not a picky guy right yeah I mean okay I
lie I'm a picky yeah I'm a picky guy
yeah um but for this like when it's a
video shoot I'm kind of I'm like
whatever gets it done yes
whatever whatever we do to do like
you're not there for a holiday no no if
it's a holiday and and this happened I'd
be like excuse me
where is my king bed yeah I I would have
okay so we we rented the sleeping bag
pillow set we got this pillow and it's
literally just this like it's it's just
a floatable like device it would blow it
up yeah it's like a pool noodle yeah
it's fine it's fine but it's like I feel
bad when I'm asking like like uh I I got
Pete and um diet has joined me and I
feel bad when I'm like hey guys come
join me by the way you're gonna be on
camera for 13 hours and you have to
sleep on a on an air pillow yeah yeah I
was just like I'm sorry guys man I mean
we can buy real pills if you're like no
that's fine it's fine it just sucks you
just want a real pillow sometimes why
didn't you just like go to like a donkey
and get a like a cheap ass pillar yeah
probably should have done that yeah
didn't have much time yeah I'm I'm gonna
out myself for a bit I didn't sleep on
the other yeah he didn't okay I think
okay immersion ruin immersion I know I
know so I I got there on uh on the third
day and I remember like I had I had a
[__] mission getting to the RV on
like the first day yourself
um and I remember you know at the end of
the third day everyone was [__]
knackered and you could tell right you
can tell the difference between you know
dietus and Pete who I would say have
been creating content for like unless
a shorter amount of time than I have
because I'm like when the cameras are
off I'm like okay we need to do a shoot
tomorrow I need to be well rested they
were being great mates and they'll be
like oh let's let's do the RV experience
it's you know we're fine with it we
don't need the pillow I got that and I
remember I remember asking so where am I
sleeping and they told me where I'm
sleeping and I measured it out and I'm
like I can't even I was the tallest
and I was like do we have a pillow and
they were like no
I was like in my head I was planning out
okay am I am I how am I gonna am I how
am I gonna sleep am I gonna like take my
coat out use that as a pillow luckily
there was a that was the day where there
was like an extra like two beds that
they had booked for that day yeah every
day I put like a what an extra a bunch
of extra beds in the hotel or whatever
just because it was like all right if
somebody wants to I'm gonna be like you
have to sleep in the RV I'm like yeah
I'll do it because I feel like it's my
thing and I should yeah but anyone else
I'm like [__] it go sleep in there yeah
for sure yeah yeah yeah so you know
after the cameras had rolled off it was
like you know 10 30 or something the
staff were like everyone's knackered the
stuff like all right last call is anyone
going to sleep in the Hotel La this is
your last chance and I turn over to a
like uh Pete and die this was like are
you gonna take the bed and they were
like nah man we gotta stay here we're
gonna stay here please stay you you take
it to bed now I gotta stay here man I'm
like I'll be honest guys I kind of want
to sleep in a bed tonight and we're
we're on camera tomorrow for like 13
hours so
I've had enough shoots in my life that
uh because here's the thing I remember
when I first started like doing IRL
content you know I really wanted to get
involved and immersed and now like how
many years after trash Chase I'm like I
just want a good night's sleep event if
I know I'm making content you can say
that because you've experienced the
trash taste road trip oh yeah that's
that where like that gave me so much
knowledge into just how important a good
night's sleep is holy [__] I I think it
was because of the trash test road trip
where I was like I'm gonna be real
Connor I wanna bet tonight you know just
just go get out of here yeah
have a good night
I mean I I would have done it if there
was no option available because that's
what I signed up for but I was like if
the options available amen I'm gonna
take it man I'm gonna take it I'm sorry
I'm sorry okay yes I'm weak-willed okay
yes I know I know okay this is fine yeah
I have to yeah I think what's important
you're on the stream yeah yeah exactly
right exactly uh but it was fun yeah it
was great it was a ton of planning a
[__] ton of planning to get it all to do
because we had to find like activities
to do every day yeah that was cool and
would be interesting and we had to make
sure that we'd get signal and if we
didn't figure out the solutions I like
uh yeah because I wanted to stream it in
basically 4K so because because twitch
doesn't let you stream in 4k because
um it's terrible in that sense and
doesn't let you do it I've I've
complained so many times I'm like twitch
please let me stream 4K but they say no
um so but you can like still stream in
4k and then down sample to 1080P and it
still looks great yeah yeah so I really
wanted to test out this 4K equipment and
test out a camera with a better
microphone uh to really try and and make
the IRL stuff feel more uh what's the
word uh upscale yeah I don't know like
more pretty much higher quality yeah
yeah like it feels more like a TV show
yeah where the camera doesn't stop
rolling for sure yeah yeah which has its
benefits and having sound size but
um and and you know it seemed pretty
possible you just need a [__] ton of
internet and good internet because you
need to you need like five to four times
the uh bandwidth of a normal IRL stream
yeah for a 4K stream so it's a lot a lot
more stuff going on right and it breaks
way more often so I you know I kind of
kind of was looking around I started
asking a bunch of people who knew all
this stuff better than me I was like
what camera is the best for this also
how do I do this and how do I literally
do everything so you go and ask someone
like hey what camera do I use then you'd
be like you go to the guy who knows how
the all the software works like Hey will
this camera work with this this guy told
me to get this camera he's like yeah I
mean theoretically and then and then and
then I needed oh dude there's so many so
many little things that went wrong
before I even started the RV trip where
I was like I don't even know this is
going to make sense like
um the the this new thing came out
basically like all streamers have like
two ways uh of broadcasting there's
these two like boxes there's like a more
a cheaper more custom one that's harder
to use
um but the benefit if it is that you
don't have to pay like a monthly
subscription and the one that most
people use is this one that you pay a
monthly subscription for yeah
um and it's a bit more expensive and has
less kind of uh what's the word like uh
customization
um and and that that company that did
that one brought out a bigger one that
could do 4K so I was like okay this is
let's do it let's do it yeah and then it
turned out like to get it to work you
need to do a bunch of weird stuff that
was like what and then you and then
you'd connect two modems to One USB
thing yeah how do you connect two modems
to One USB where you need a USB splitter
yeah and then that doesn't work for some
reason and then I asked the company had
to get them I had to like speed dial the
company and be like hey how do I get
this to work because in the in the guide
it says you can do this like oh no you
need a you need a specific cable that
isn't released yet I'm like what
what but then they're like oh we can
send you some though and I was like oh
cool but like how was I supposed to know
this yeah so luckily they sent me those
and they arrived in time yeah this whole
[__] headache this has been even
before you even planned what we're doing
you're getting the RV getting how are we
gonna film this thing how are we gonna
do it basically how to get a headache
yeah we got it to work though
um and it looked pretty damn good I
think the first part yeah like we we had
to get creative with some solutions so
we even bought like a starlink internet
um which uh [__] hell to get that to
work remotely we had to I bought like a
giant power generator thing like uh yeah
no it's more like the final four oh man
yeah it's like a it's a it's a like a
giant giant battery that you charge and
it takes hours it's basically just a
generator at this point right it's a
generator basically uh and then you
basically like we we only we only had
you luckily thank God we only had to use
it like once or twice
um because it could get like way better
internet than any of the cell phone
towers could give us yeah but it's just
like you know you're trying to stream
and then you're like all right what's
the internet oh I got it [__] and then
you're on camera like okay okay and then
you're like all right can we can we get
the thing out can we hook it all up and
it's like you're just juggling so many
things and you're constantly checking
all the text working uh and then there's
other stuff like there's a we have the
tracker on the map it shows you where I
am but I have to do that as well so it's
like you're juggling just like five
thousand seven this is why like as much
as I want to try more IRL streams I'm
just so scared to because I did not want
to deal with that stress like yeah it
sounds like a [__] nightmare but you
can just hire me now I'll do it for you
we get a mate right going yeah I mean
and it sucks because it's like I I try
to show these guys how it all works uh
and like with people who are bring along
but it's so tough to explain people how
a lot of this stuff works and if it
breaks how to fix it yeah yeah so it's
still like if something breaks more
often not it's like all right guys gone
entertain I'm gonna go and fix
everything real quick
um and it's very frustrating but I think
it's worth it in the long run like it's
a ton of stress and it's a ton of
anxiety
um about if it's if it's working but I
think um I think the results speak for
themselves it looked amazing yeah what
activities
I'm just too busy talking about the tech
yeah that's the polished
um yeah everyone's like but the Dolphins
though the Dolphins yeah we went um so
day one we did
um we so we started in um we picked up
the avian Shin Osaka yeah which is the
bullet train stop in Osaka we drove to
Allergy and then we started there and so
day one was just all of Hawaii Island
which is beautiful it's a stunning
Island that connects uh Mainland Japan
to Chicago and it's also a weird [__]
yeah they have so much touristy stuff
though like if you're a tourist you
shouldn't sleep on Elijah Island it's so
cool they have so much uh support for
English-speaking tourists as well and
they have a [__] ton of stuff yeah so
much anime stuff on oji island as well
yeah they're the Naruto theme park and
the Hello Kitty hotel I think yeah it's
all there yeah and a bunch of other just
like why is this so much yeah uh you
know one of the biggest challenges of
doing IRL
um normally is getting permission yeah
uh and we had such a big rig where there
was no way we could like you know kind
of go in sneak around yeah I don't even
stick around but like hope that it would
just kind of be okay like we had such a
big rig that like we had to get in
contact with everywhere and arrange
everything beforehand yeah um so the
career in it now yeah
but luckily like everything we've got
permission for it was all chill and it
was great so day one we did um we uh did
a Zen experience in this like Bond
villain headquarters conveniently that's
not a day I was there yeah so you know
Pete got the dub on that one yeah yeah
yeah we had like fun we kind of made a
fun challenge out of everything yeah and
it was like dude this thing was sick you
guys would love it God would love it
yeah it was literally just this wooden a
beautiful wooden structure that just
extends over this view of like a bunch
of trees and a bunch of landscapes in
awaji and you can just meditate with a
professional I guess zen master
that was there there was a Thai woman
yeah because I I saw I saw the clip of
like the woman introducing you and I was
like I think I hear a Thai accent yeah
yeah it wouldn't surprise me I think his
name was uh Bilal was it Bilal UH no the
woman no the the guy yeah
from Virginia who had trained trained
with uh you know the nurses uh I think
like masters of meditation in in Japan
but I think they're originally from
India but so he learned everything in
Japanese
I think an Indian guy I think so yeah
again but he he basically just you know
went through it and he's he was awesome
he was up for the banter even though we
were kind of you know trying to make a
joke or two while meditating yeah it was
so much fun it was great and then and
then we went to do uh kawara tiles which
we've done before yeah yeah uh but then
I I beat my record and I beat their
their local record in that oh yeah I saw
that clip yeah that was so fun that
place was great they they had costumes
there was it was literally like this
this like John Wick or kind of it was so
reminiscent of like martial arts fight
scenes the bottom floor of this this uh
building it was literally the factory
right it looked like a set piece of like
like old boys yeah yeah like a factory
because it looked like it didn't look
like a real factory it looked like a
factory in a movie yeah um and then just
above this Factory was a kawara
experience were you going them oh yeah
and I managed to break 34 tiles hey
which is [__] insane I didn't think I
could do it and then just yeah I was
like oh did you like kind of build
yourself up to that yeah we did um we
did 20 and we've been there for about
two hours I think at that point we were
kind of like all right we should wrap it
up and I thought just for fun let's just
give it let's let's just go to 34
because we've gone up by five and I was
like just add 14. oh because the record
was 33 right I was like [__] it up I'll
beat it but obviously I didn't think I
was gonna beat it but I thought it'd be
visually pretty funny because yeah yeah
um and then somehow smashed it yeah you
got it it was the Bruce Lee costume man
that gave you the power yeah
and then yeah I did it and that was fun
and then we did like barbecuing and then
day two we did um we went from awaji
Island all the way over
um to Chicago the northern part and then
went to okayama above just above okay
I'm Camp there for the night oh so you
went through the uh setonaikai like
driving trail that we did the cycling
special go through that side or oh no
you
they're so cute dude and all the staff
are so kind and they were so nice and
you know and it seemed like they really
were like obsessed with those Dolphins
it seemed like they really loved it yeah
um it was fun man damn Dolphins did they
did they meet the hype do dolphins meet
the hype the dolphin hype I'm still I'm
still precarious about dolphins
everybody wrote about them but I think I
think we've talked to mail in one too
many times yeah yeah he's made me scared
of dolphins they were cute though they
were cute they're so incredibly smart
though like oh yeah oh it shows oh yeah
yeah yeah I I'm pretty sure they're
smarter than me
very intelligent creatures yeah yeah and
it was nice and the uh that whole area
did they feel like because I've like
like rubber
yeah yeah they like rub they feel like
rubber honestly like Smooth rubber I
don't know how to describe it it's a
very it's very odd yeah yeah because
like a wet rubber yeah that was so cool
to stream because the clips of it look
awesome like the the quality of it
considering would just on a pier in the
ocean yeah we're pretty like far out
from the coast yeah yeah and it's really
cool like this sorry it looks awesome
yeah and again I I just my whole thing
is that like originally for me this
whole which sounds so weird to say like
this whole RV's trip was kind of like a
test in my mind to see if this could
work and you know now that I see that it
went really well I kind of want to try
and do it again but maybe bigger and see
how I can improve it yeah
um make it more more easy on everyone
involved as well so yeah it's not
exhausted all the time uh but yeah the
dolphin thing was great that day
and they they told us about dolphins
they gave us a little quiz about how to
what did you learn
how to tell between a male and a female
dolphin didn't know that oh okay didn't
know that so the one that has the
massive [__]
is the male they have more lines I guess
or spaces where maybe baby dolphins
would come out of and where they would
do the Deeds right um uh that's the
difference I found out they taught us
not to put trash in the ocean been doing
that anyway
I've been on a good run with that yeah
yeah and then we went to a went to this
open air theater uh uh near the dolphin
place and do this this open air theater
is sick like as in like what like like a
drive-in theater or something what's the
official what's the like the actual name
Amphitheater yeah oh okay it's like and
if you it's like this stunning theater
and it's behind it is the ocean oh wow
if you stand in this one specific spot
your voice like completely resonates so
loudly that it's it's like a megaphone
oh you're just talking right only in
this one specific spot you have to stand
there if you and you move one step and
then you sound normal and you step step
and say exact spot and it's like boom
it's like it's like just gets like
absolutely like it's insane physics yeah
it's like what the [__] how how do they
do that I didn't I know it's physics but
like it was so impressive that just a
volume difference yeah yeah it's blew my
mind and we had a little answer that
went really well Pete won the township
uh while it was snowing in the middle of
nowhere where gone eventually came and
joined us yeah like 1am after the stream
ended yeah but we were in the middle of
I don't even know we didn't even use the
starlink that night but we had we had
really good signal in the middle of the
mountains in no City we were like an
hour away from any City I have no idea
how we had any signal